when a kid show becomes too popular it
becomes a subject to plenty of concerns
from the parents and because Peppa Pig
is one of the most popular kid shows
there is it had to go through plenty of
controversies you'd never see coming
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up and subscribe to the things now let's
check out the horrible truth about Peppa
Pig a banned episode say what how can a
kid show that's so loved have an
inappropriate episode that was actually
banned well it turns out that Peppa Pig
actually isn't loved everywhere around
the world there's a country that had to
ban an episode that country was
Australia and the reason was simple it
showed spiders the episodes called mr.
skinnylegs
and it talks about encouraging kids to
play with spiders rather than hurt them
in the episode daddy pig tells Peppa
that she should be nice to the spider as
a spider is so little it can't really
harm her Peppa actually ends up if
friending the spider and even giving it
a name the truth is that's really not
how orcs in Australia playing with a
spider just isn't as simple in Australia
as it might be elsewhere which is why
this particular episode had to be banned
spiders in Australia are a lot more
dangerous than spiders from anywhere
else this was one of the show's most
controversial moments because even
though the show itself was pulled off
the air in Australia the episode was
actually still available on the online
publication a few years ago the episode
became available again but because the
parents complained about the possibility
of their kids playing with Australian
spiders Nick jr. decided it would be
safer to just pull the episode and avoid
any controversies repeating themselves
but those aren't the only controversies
the show is faced during its time on air
so far slammed by British doctors here's
an interesting controversy the British
Medical Journal criticized Peppa Pig for
something you'd never even expect anyone
who criticizes show about well to be
fair you probably never expected British
healthcare to criticise one of the most
beloved British shows and yet here we
are
Peppa Pig has been criticised by the
British Medical Journal for fostering
unrealistic expectations of family
doctors and the general medical
practice the journal presented three
cases of the shows inappropriate conduct
when it came to medicine
when Peppa's brother had a rash on his
face the family called a doctor who then
prescribed her medicine but the actual
doctor says that this could just
encourage people to visit their doctors
more than necessary as rashes like that
go away on their own in another instance
the family doctor comes after the piglet
suffers from regular cold symptoms the
doctor that wrote the journal highlights
that British hospitals are under a lot
of strain and are often overworked
Hospital waiting times are always
soaring in the UK and the doctor thinks
that unnecessary scenes like that can
make people think they're experiencing
something they absolutely need a doctor
for when in fact it's something that
would easily go away on its own of
course you should always visit a doctor
if you think your condition is
developing into something serious but in
general it's always recommended to treat
things like colds and rashes with just
regular antibiotics still not convinced
it gets better
fat-shaming this is the one the parents
have a serious problem with essays have
been written on the fat shaming topics
in Peppa Pig the character that's
usually the victim of these jokes is
their dad since Bubba's family are well
pigs they're naturally a bit more chunky
but fitting into the stereotype the dad
is obviously chunkier than anyone else
the show has a running gag of Peppa and
the rest of the family casually joking
about their dad's big belly a parent
heavily criticised the episode where the
family tries to go into the tree house
Peppa set up a password and of course
the password is daddy's big tummy after
the dad tries to climb in but can't
everyone laughs at him and pebble
repeats that his tummy is just too big
there's even an episode where the dad
tries to get fit but here comes Peppa
telling him that his tummy's too big to
be naturally fit these jokes just keep
on going and going and it apparently
doesn't sit well with the parents whose
kids are repeating Peppa's words you can
find a fat shaming joke in just about
every episode pointing out that someone
has a big tummy just isn't OK in the
real world and could lead to terrible
consequences do you think Peppa Pig
takes it too far with the fat shaming
jokes let us know in the comments health
and safety issues what's the number one
rule for being safe in a car if you
answered wearing
belt you get a thousand points and guess
which show doesn't get a thousand points
if you answered Peppa Pig you get
another thousand that's right if you
watch the earlier episodes of Peppa Pig
you'll notice that peppa and George
never wear their seat belts in the car
seems pretty dangerous right this
instance caught the attention of the
viewers who quickly inform Nick jr. and
told them what they think this force the
Peppa Pig characters to put on their
seatbelts whenever they drive around and
in case you didn't think this was a big
deal
millions of kids watch Peppa and since
the show is supposed to be educational
it should really teach good things and
good manners to the kids shouldn't it
we're glad the characters put on their
seatbelts to show the actual kids what
they're supposed to do in the car one of
the reasons why the characters weren't
initially buckled up is because
according to the producers it limits the
chances to show more of their
expressions as they're driving but
another producer stated that buckling
them up is a good idea because
everything Peppa does reflects what a
child does in the real world anyway and
while they're all buckled up in the car
Peppa still doesn't wear a helmet when
she's driving although she does have a
life jacket for anytime she's in a boat
have you seen Peppa Pig what do you
think about these controversies that are
surrounding one of the most popular
British shows ever make sure to let us
know in the comments and that's all for
our video don't forget to subscribe to
the things thanks for watching see you
next time
[Music]